the gyro can experience right well
that's where the benefit of bad things
actually comes in sometimes like some of
the best things are bad things that are
good by accident right yeah like that
the rule movie movie yeah we
I used to introduce that movie in New
York for I did it for a promo thing for
Comedy Central first but then I had
never seen the movie so I kept going
back and like hosting it and then we
made a fake sequel to it this guy George
glass and he he knew Tommy so Tommy
would leave these long messages it's
[ __ ] string that's how long ago this
was and the guy who played uh oh hi Mark
Greg his name is he wrote that book that
they made the movie that guy's cool [ __ ]
oh the guy who plays mark yeah and uh
but the other guy the one who got a
[ __ ] and he had like who's shiver me
timbers or something mm-hmm because he
left his under I left me underwears in
your remember that guy and gets a blow
job and on what's-his-name squeeze O's
couch god I don't remember that yeah I
remember every character I saw it a
bunch of times I don't think I've ever
seen it all the way through dude and
then 14 scenes I've never gone now I
never went to uh it has like it well at
the time I don't know if it does now but
a head like that Rocky Horror Picture
Show yeah thing which I never did that
so at movie theaters people go and like
this movie group watching it you it
feels like right to yell at it I swear
to God like I am mean I thought it was
like a I'm like I'm not gonna get
immediately I was like oh this I really
understand this and people yell off
sometimes of a band playing and like
yeah it was great it's [ __ ] all it's
the Rocky Horror Picture Show they do
that because they actually like it yeah
this is a different vibe yeah it's very
hard I mean he's genuinely a [ __ ]
maniac
and hard to deal with I had to have to
Ida had my girlfriend and another friend
dress kind of like [ __ ] and distract
him so he wouldn't see the parody thing
we made before we showed it and then we
look at the reviews
yeah but that did nobody listen to make
a thing that's watch ibly bad is like
that's a beautiful thing that can only
it is rarely happen yeah it's it's
interesting like the the room is so
unfeasibly bad it has become a cult hit
trust me this is the worst movie you
will ever see ever in your internal life
ever but it's it's like but it's amazing
because when they say worst they have to
be I mean we watchable where it's not
boring that's the thing right it's just
not more amazing so I think that's like
real lightning in a bottle it's the
worst movie because they're trying to
make a good movie it's not the worst
movie to watch I think it's the best to
go to a thing on theater of people it's
like the best people shouting at the
screen because you have cancer cancer
it's such a crazy movie when did you see
it when did you only see I've only seen
it on like I guess it was DVD at the
time hmm or what and I only watch like
part of it then I had to shut it off and
I can't do this did you oversee the
dough member that I remember those
billboards Jamie when I when I lived
here early in the Hollywood days when
right after they made this movie I would
drive around see that billboard it was
up there forever forever he had the room
the movie like ah the room movie calm he
drive by it like what year was that like
I'm trying to remember
I've I might have made it up because I'm
like I've seen this life like I've seen
it in person I don't know what he might
have had he might have had it up still
he was he had a billboard up forever you
know here was the movie made that
doesn't three it said what yeah how's
that possible well I missed it I I would
have thought it was way earlier than
that video most multiple billboards it's
where it was coming soon how old is he
nobody knows you know I never saw the
top one coming soon like how old is he I
don't know he's it looks like an older
fella
but there's a couple movies like that
like showgirls isn't moving like that or
so I don't remember it I just say do you
remember that's a it's a good one at the
end of elizabeth berkley after that
it's hard to bounce back from some of
those movies but because the movie is so
bad or because it was uh you know who
knows man
she went from Saved by the Bell to being
a dirty girl
she's so did screech they brought back
Saved by the Bell
yeah it's later okay yes Wow looking
good freak I just made it
Mario Lopez looking good everybody's
looking good so what are they coming
back as the other the parents yeah
there's a bunch of jokes referring to it
and there's much new jokes about like
iPads and screech screech was out there
doing the book behind the Bell or
something like that
screech was doing stand-up there was
Skippy from Family Ties remember when he
was doing stand-up yes remember I lived
with him Judah Friedlander this is Renee
oh that's right yeah he says right we're
just like be in his room he was like he
would smoke pot all day and then he
would come out and be like did you it
was like a just I'm gonna have a
sandwich and I'm not gonna touch it for
a while but I want that so and he would
always got freaked out by missing a call
to something what happened to him does
he still do stand-up now or no I don't
know no I'm CeCe I used to I was this
thing is that what it said Hugo yeah
like he's dirty now let's give you with
notes get it I don't know he would
always be there like I never met him I
don't think maybe I made him one time
but he would always be on the wall I
coming next week escape you from family
times remember those the first guy that
I worked in a club where he worked then
I was like oh yeah that guy from TV he's
coming next week
[Applause]